i want people to see the cancer journey
as you're not alone
it is ugly and it takes all hands on
deck
and in that journey i had to learn as
a husband as her best friend i have to
protect provide negative reach
the biggest challenge we are facing
right now is my health let's go knock
this last one out
so far i've had seven rounds of chemo
even though it may be a tough season
i feel like god has been good to us
you're not going anywhere
i'm not going anywhere i'm gonna drive
you crazy i'm gonna take off my boots
and leave my dirty socks in the living
room
for the next 40 years well first off
congratulations
on your own netflix series country ever
after thank you my name is cafe anderson
i
am an independent country music artist
can we country it up for you now i'm
from bangs texas but now i live in los
angeles california
i am married to the baddest woman on the
planet christila anderson
when and how did the idea come about for
your
own family tv series okay so
i was laying in a bed my wife and i just
were just waking up
i said honey what is y e s spell she
said yes
i said babe what does e y e s spell she
said
yes we have 57 million views cats
so then from that we go into
um alex baskin from evolution gets a
call from
bravo and they're like hey we got a
possible couple you need to meet
and so i'm going to meet alex he created
a little small show
called house files of orange county and
house laws of atlanta
and he sent a camera crew to our house
and 12 episodes later
the the seraphim herself roma downey
comes floating in on a cloud you know
and she says i love y'all and mark
brunette and her
about 12 episodes and netflix says yes
it's a blessing it's bigger than us it
was supposed to happen this way
it was lightning in a bottle four
different times it has a lot to do with
the climate of our country
it has a lot to do with our second year
of marriage
our first year marriage we fought every
day we woke up every day and argued
every day
every day and and our second year
we decided to fight for each other and
not with each other
and we that's just kind of been our
mantra is team anderson i'm going to
fight for
you and not leave and so that's where we
are right now
a lot of different people can relate to
it on you know
different levels whether you have the
aspiring singer or just anybody
in the industry that they're in who can
relate to you of having to do a lot of
things yourself
and and chase a dream and then you have
of course people who
are struggling with their own health
issues who can relate to your family
and then you know you have mixed race
couples
also watching and you're representing
them on
tv which we don't see a lot of i mean
what does that mean to you
you know it's funny because the things
that
you thought would actually hold you back
what makes the show fun
so it's city it's country it's black
it's white it's
fun it's it's inspiring it works what do
you and your wife
really hope that fans take away from
this show
that they're not crazy that you're that
your family
is not the only family that's nuts and
like when paw paw comes in
my dad is blunt
he's cajon he is blunt he is who he is
but
is his love genuine yes and can we love
anyway
can we love anyway you don't have to
date someone that's just like you
i would not want to date someone just
like me i can't i can't
my wife doesn't eat meat i love ribs i'm
a ribologist
okay hallelujah that's just me but we
fit
and in the middle of that motive it can
can you be motivated can you fight for
each other yes
can you build a business with with the
internet access
and a cell phone you can and you can do
very well by doing that can you think
outside the box
when was the last time we gave our
ourselves permission to be great
well let's have you give yourself
permission to be great and love those
around you
love as hard as you can while you can
you know it's man when did we lose those
things i hope we never lose those things
you guys have been very vulnerable and
open
with her journey and her battle with
cancer and and sharing that with the
world
what do you hope that people take away
from
seeing that journey on camera that
i want people to see the cancer journey
as you're not alone
it is ugly and it takes all hands on
deck
i know people that feel like oh i'm it's
i'm going to go to chemo i'm going to go
to radiation
i'm going to go natural or holistic and
it's my fight it's not
it's not it's all it takes all of us and
in that journey i had to learn to
as a as a husband as her best friend i
have to protect provide negative bleach
i got to teach my kids preaching i got
to protect them you know and i have to
also provide for them
in that one of the first days that we
were filming she had a really bad
reaction to chemo
and she's nauseous she's fading in and
out
of being sleepy awake all that and i
asked the camera crew
y'all leave i got to take care of her
and in two minutes they were out of our
house
and she leans over to me not a lot of
strength and says they need to see this
you got to let them in and in that i had
to learn that
how can a husband learn to protect his
wife and be with her unless he watches
what i'm doing and i learned that by
watching my dad when my
my mother lost her battle to cancer 17
days before my 11th birthday
i saw my dad literally pick her up when
she was too weak
and put on the bathtub and cook for her
and do those things so
i learned that from watching stan and
somebody's gonna learn that from
watching me
and when you say for better for worse
and sickness and hell
you gotta mean it you gotta mean and
it's it's the everyday thing
is it every day it ain't it ain't like
that all the time
and and people have to realize that like
i said our first year of marriage we all
get every day
you know and it was little things but
are you gonna love anyway
yeah they're gonna keep your eyes on the
big picture anyway and that's what
country ever after does
you're gonna laugh you're gonna cry
you're gonna pull for us
and hopefully um people are gonna save
it so you gotta hit the little reminder
button it's a bell on netflix here's a
little bit you gotta hit the little bell
says remind me
you don't get this country love girl do
the kids understand
really like what the cameras are all
about and then when they watch episodes
with you guys
do they what is their reaction when they
see themselves
on a show they are tickled brown
i ain't they tickle pink they take a
beige whatever skin though
they love it because they're like that's
me that's us and we had this premiere
and all their friends are there with
them and it's cool to see them
get excited and and laugh at themselves
and and
for us to enjoy it the cameras the first
two days they were hugging the camera
people
so the camera guys in there you know
everly rose would wake up
and she's like morning and she's hugging
everybody's leg
you know oh my goodness
so they had to get you okay you can't
say hi to the producer that's sitting in
the corner
you can't hug the cameraman you know
leave
demetrius alone leave him alone he does
have soft legs it is warm i get it
gotta say like your family is so
adorable
i i need more and i feel like the fans
are gonna want more
are there already conversations for a
season two there are there are
conversations
for season two christmas came early
but we gotta get we gotta get netflix we
got we gotta get we gotta get them to
say yes so
um we're gonna pray about it we are
going to
yep we are going to pray about it and i
that is another thing that i love about
you
is that you are a man of faith i mean
you met your wife at church and we see
how important faith is for not
only you personally but also in your
professional life and then
in this family unit what role does your
faith play in that
in keeping you on track every test you
have
makes your testimony and so and every
mess you have makes your mastimony
it whatever it all fits but at this
point
we have to continue to lean on each
other and the times when i'm not strong
i lay my head on chris silva and the
times that she's not strong
she leans her head on me i think we have
a good
blend of people around us in in in
hollywood and entertainment in nashville
in new york city
you don't have your relatives but you
can make a good family
you can make a good family and there's
good people in each one of these bubbles
that we leaned on and we wouldn't be
here without them so don't be on island
number one because islands are hard when
i say don't be an island don't be by
yourself
allow people to help you and that's hard
for me it's always been hard for me
but we need it we need it we're seeing
your journey this season it's crazy
a journey that you started back in 2005
as an independent artist
what do you hope to be next for you i
don't know anything different but
independent
i come out of texas i come watching pat
green and i i
actually patted my country business plan
after the hip hop rappers in houston
so you got mike job who mike chow
you know i learned from those guys and
if if there's an opportunity for a major
label to say we want to license your
music and get it out
because right now mr red white and blue
a song that i wrote after meeting
sergeant craig carter who's a
united states marine went viral on tick
tock it's in the top 40 of the country
charts right now with no radio airplane
mr red white and blue lay down
here's a line
of white and blue there is a different
wave with the internet that country
artists can tap into
and i've been so blessed to do that so
blessed to do that god has just
blessed and honored my hard work